hey what's up everyone matthew and cena
here thank you for joining us for
another
live stream what day of the week is it
is it thursday i think it's thursday
thank you all for joining us i'm so
excited to be with you again let us know
in the comments
where you're tuning in from today we
have a very special guest
a friend of ours whose background is in
design
and branding but after working
diligently for
a whole year practicing her illustration
skills
she's become a professional illustrator
and she made a career transition
so joining us today is joanna barrow
welcome to the show
yeah joanna
thank you for having me and i'm really
excited to share it with you please
allow me some mistakes
um i've been in just for a year so yeah
there were plenty of that so
i think that i think that story is more
relatable the more mistakes we could see
today
and the more mistakes you can share with
us throughout the process
even better because you're human we're
all human and
the fact that you're even able to make
this transition over a year
that's scary for a lot of people so
the bumps and bruises all of those
things are relevant for us to hear and
understand because we know it's not easy
but we're thankful that you're able to
share your journey with us
cool i think i'll jump right into the
presentation because
it will help me to kind of show you
visually what do i mean by the
transition
so i just wanted to say that
everything you see online usually it's a
lie
so when you see a good tutorial it
usually means that
it's a tutorial and it's meant to be
pretty so
just to warn you today you're not going
to see a pretty tutorial it would be
something with a lot of mistakes i'm not
even sure if it will come out
good but you'll be the one to judge
and i just wanted it to be candid
because i want you to see life that
in order to make anything good you first
need to make a lot of bad things
and very often with the artists we don't
see
where they started because they've been
studying maybe this at the university
maybe their parents already supported
their work when they were kids
but when you jump in at the age of 30
like i did then
you kind of have to start from the
beginning and that's that's okay
and i think the first human drawing i
did was
um looking like that and it lacked
any features and actually this is quite
a good drawing still
so i recommend you if you have any
doubts to go to my instagram
account and if you scroll all the way
down i kept everything there
and you will see the drawings like oh my
god i drew i made a picture of a
schmitzer
and i drew on it because i just didn't
know what i'm doing so it was
really really bad it's still better than
mine
that's the first it's letting you know
that's still better than mine i have no
illustrator by any means so that still
looks great
i'm not sure if you go there you will
see what i mean um
and i was a little worried to come in
and like discl even expose it more
because i was like my clients are going
to see this and
they pay me a lot of money for
illustration today right
but that's the part of the process and
that's like kind of my story so
i want to be handed about it so thank
you
then in august i got a little bit better
i'm not sure if better or worse because
i added some features but i think it
still looked a little bit funny
um in november i think it started to
actually look like an
illustration so i was quite happy and
actually in october was the first time
when i got my commission
um it was first commission and it was um
my first 500 bucks made on the
illustration which
was a lot having in mind i never done it
so
it means that it's just possible if you
want to do it even if you don't know how
to draw
and today it looks like this and
actually some of my audience is
complaining
that they prefer the old blue girl
um they feel like there is more style to
it and that also means that
perfection is not always what people are
looking for so
sometimes you can just like be yourself
and that's fine for somebody
who needs something like that so yeah no
it's it's really good to see this
journey and
it's it's interesting and also good to
see that you're kind of drawing the same
thing at
each of these milestones is that
something
that you do like every month are you
just drawing this
same girl every single time or like how
did we get to this how do why do we have
four of the same thing at different
milestones in your life i think i do
this every time i kind of feel that
i improved something so i don't have a
set timeline but whenever i feel like
okay
this time i learned some shading let's
see
how does it apply and it also challenges
me because it's the same drawing
so it challenges me to see okay did you
really improve because
i don't know it's just a easy way for me
to see if i put
goods the skills to use actually no i
think that's actually a fantastic test
for yourself because i've never
considered doing this
but if you think about any other
discipline like let's say in martial
arts
right if you want to get your belt they
teach you certain things along the way
and then they make you they test you
to see if how well you you can do it and
if you've gotten better
and that's how you move up in the
ranking so as a designer as an
artist i never consider doing this where
you're trying to make the same thing
and just applying the new thing that you
learned and i think that's a fantastic
way for anyone who's looking for
uh skill development whatever that might
be set up a test like this where it's
like okay i'm gonna do
one piece and let me learn something and
let me add something new
let me add another layer i think that's
pretty cool
i think the most important part story is
also that
if i compare myself to other artists i
would be pretty depressed i think
because
um they are really really good so if i
at least look at this then i have more
positive feedback okay i'm improving um
there is no reason to compare
we are just different at different stage
in our we are all moving forward just
in a different speed so that's okay
you're making progress
yeah and that's that's where you want to
actually be so that's fantastic
that's really good feeling and it helps
you to like kind of keep moving so
um now i wanted to share with you like
kind of three things that
helped me in this process to keep moving
and like made it easy and possible even
for me to do it
and one of them is just the technical
part of the drawing
one of them is like adding feelings to
it
to kind of understand the emotion of the
illustration
and the last part is the conceptual part
which is how to come up with these
ideas so um
for the conceptual part i noticed that
some of the students i've been working
with they say
i don't have the ideas like they some of
them can draw just perfectly
you will be surprised i'm like the worst
from my students
and but they don't do anything and
they're like why you are on the show why
i am not on the show i draw so much
better
because you just don't show your work
you know just
[Music]
and they say but i don't know what to
draw and i say like don't
forget about it like you are the concept
you have
all the answers you just kind of have to
um
trust in your experience and the things
that you already know
and perhaps what will help you with that
is if you could actually specialize in
something and i know we talk about
it a lot in branding but it applies also
here
and for example i from the beginning i
really wanted to draw about mental
health
not because i came up with the industry
but because um
i was on the side of the patient i also
worked with a lot of psychologists and
psychiatrists to develop their
businesses
so i kind of had the expertise i felt
like
and this was something i could talk
about for hours
like if you ask me don't ask me actually
don't because
i would just not stop talking but
this special specialization helped me to
always kind of have the concept at hand
and
help me also to connect with the clients
who needed
illustration work and
once i knew what my theme is then i was
naturally curious like if i talk to my
friends on to the family
i would like kind of dive in on the
topic which would
help me to build my expertise and it was
very natural i didn't have to force it
um it was like
more pleasant process and then you just
kind of move on
and like forget it you know this is what
you like to talk about it so if you like
dogs it could be dogs
if you like uh if you have other
interests you can pick anything because
some people say like
oh you have like this glorious cause and
i don't care for things like this
and then fine it can be dogs that's fine
it doesn't have to be
something big i i think there's a lot of
truth to that i just wanted to say
because uh greg gunn who's also an
illustrator at the future
uh before for fun he did his dog walker
series and i think after that he got
hired professionally to do
a bunch of dog illustrations i think it
might have been for facebook or
something like that
but same thing it's like you just pick a
lane something that you're either
passionate about or you specialize in or
have a lot of knowledge
about and then you just start doing your
craft through that
another person that comes to mind is uh
jack butcher from
visualize value like he loves philosophy
and he's he loves design and he's
combining those two things his passion
for philosophy
through the lens of a designer and
that's how he grew and made
visualized value so it's great to hear
this story again from from your angle
somebody who studied mental health who's
had a lot of past clients like that
and then now you're using your
illustrations um as
as another medium to filter that message
or specialty through so
just wanted to share more context there
because that's fantastic that you're
you're sharing this with us definitely
and i think the dog idea actually came
from greg
i'm sorry i think i just seen it
recently and that's why it came to me so
it you have it all of us have the
concept
in you like you have your stories you
have your experience so you just kind of
have to
pick the one you like the most and um
then i would recommend to just keep
writing also your thoughts
so i like to use the smart notes process
but you can do anything like you can
literally use the whiteboard or
some digital notebook and just organize
these thoughts in some way
um and just you know keep it there
let it grow and you know once the brief
comes in
from a client you would just start
connecting
the dots you will look into your notes
you will have all the expertise and
you will know the solution to the
problem so whatever they come up with
or they want to draw like literally
which scene
you will kind of already know the
concept so
i think the part of specializing helps a
lot with that
yeah i'm trying to wrap my head around
this and the process and maybe some of
this we can get into when you do our
tutorial and demo but yeah just having
the knowledge being
saturated in the information as you're
trying to synthesize a solution either
as a designer as an illustrator for a
client
i think it's so important chris has
talked about this in several
uh past episodes on our main channel and
on this channel
about creativity and how to do it is
working with a client understanding the
problem then doing this deep dive
into saturating your brain with all
kinds of information and thoughts and
feelings
uh around that particular subject and
sitting on that for a while
and then letting your brain allow to do
its work and then
uh you're just setting up all the rods
for lightning to strike
so when the either once the deadline
comes through or once the client has the
ask you're ready to like boom
i know what this can be right yes and
it's a great feeling because
even though i just started it feels so
good that they come to me and i
i know what i'm doing and i even
surprise myself and actually what you
said about feelings
brings me to the next uh stage which is
once you know the concept so well you
will be able to feel the feelings that
you want to show
and showing the feelings is good way to
make the illustrations simple because
then
you can focus on the small parts like
you know really focused face
or this dog that is like really cute and
have a nice fur
and showing feeling is just a simpler
way to draw i
it seems to me it's like more natural
and you can do that through show using
symbols so i use a lot of symbols in my
work because
when i didn't know how to draw a human
figure i would just
uh draw a symbol of it um here i was
thinking of the position itself
and i used other elements but you can
pick
what technique will be the most suitable
for you to show the feelings
and here in this illustration i wanted
to show the progress the moving forward
so i wanted to engage all the senses
that's why i focused on the hair a lot
because i know that when you run the
hair is really wavy and that's a bit
romantic and i think
people like to see this in the
progress um i also use motion here
because
of course that's the easiest so like
also don't be afraid to use the
obvious because it's easier for people
to understand the concept so
that's fine as well and you can also
tell a story so you could think of
what happened before and after that
scene for example here i just knew she's
gonna come over some obstacles so i like
lifted her up
a bit like she's gonna be jumping and of
course you have to pick the right shapes
and colors
that will express those feelings so this
girl i wanted her to be really like
determined and
like i'm gonna do it and it's she's
ready
so i made her clothes like ready for the
movement and i tried all the details to
express those feelings
and i think that's a nice way to make
your illustration work a bit easier
because
you will actually you have already
expertise and then you actually
are able to feel those feelings to
transfer them into your illustration
work as well
so i want to spend a little bit of time
on this one just because it
sounds so ethereal right the idea of
using your feelings
to help define or or
motivate the work that you do and so
when you say use
feelings like i look at some of these
things like use symbols make sense but
then
things like engaging all senses and
showing motion
is it because you when you look at
something like that like hair
or these you know like blobby shapes or
textures you feel something
or is it fun when you're drawing these
things like can you expand on that a
little bit more like how do i
how do i how do i feel these things
because it might mean something to you
but
how do you know that that feels the same
way for your audience
i think i literally feel the feelings
because this illustration was for my
instagram which is for my audience and
the
whole like section is about personal
growth so
i know this i experienced this so i can
literally transfer the feelings
and this list is just like kind of
tricks and techniques to use it
but because you that's why you need to
specialize so you are able to feel the
feelings because like mental health is
really hard
so i draw about anxiety depression
uh parenting children with mental health
issues and that can be really hard to
feel you know but
i experience those to some level so i
feel really comfortable with that and
when my clients come they say i want
that and i'm like what
i don't get it and they say we want to
these feelings
in our drawing so sometimes i feel like
they don't even come for my illustration
like visually but
just the feeling that comes out of it
and when we talk about senses i mean
like
um if you want to draw let's say a
christmas card you might want
it to feel cozy so perhaps a person
could wear a warm sweater
but not only a warm sweater it should be
like really warm so perhaps the texture
should be really
exaggerated or
like some things are hard to let's say
there is a person sewing and
working on something then you could work
on the face
like like you know like really working
hard on it so
does it make sense yes that makes sense
especially the uh the sweater
idea if you want it to feel cozy if you
illustrate a nice fuzzy sweater and you
can see the nice texture on it there's
something about that
that i think you could bite down on as
an observer and also as the artist
making that
so yeah thank you thanks for answering
that and i think as we go through this i
might
pick your brain a little bit more on how
you might use that because i mean if
well let me ask now
if you're working with clients in the
mental health space how might you
show something like depression
as a symbol for instance if we use one
of your categories here how might you
show that as
a symbol i think the first question i
ask also my clients is how do they want
their audience to feel
um because we could show depression in a
really negative way
but we could also show it as a hopeful
thing
so in my work i really try to give
people hope
when it comes to mental health because
um i think it's really powerful thing
and you can really help a lot of people
so i
never try to show literally like crying
or
tears because i don't want them to be
even more sad
but if you check my instagram i actually
have the
postpartum depression illustration so it
was just a mum
sitting alone on the chair with chad and
all the moms understood it so
it depends on the eldest so maybe for
you it will not make sense and you will
not even see these symbols
right yeah because i'm not the intended
audience either
right so yeah so i hope it makes sense i
hope that maybe in the example i will be
able to explain it a bit more
yeah that let's let's go on let's move
forward because maybe you'll answer that
there
yeah um the last part of it is actually
to make the technical part
easy and here you can see the first
commission illustration i actually got
um it is a girl who has autism it was
for a charity
and um as you can see here that i
actually picked only two colors
and then i just added shades of it
and even though i managed to draw the
this part of the hand because it was
just two fingers and i actually just
took a photo of my hand
this was easy but i could not draw the
hands of the girl like i just
i couldn't get it so i just hit it
i love that so just do that like
make it easy like don't overthink oh my
god i can't draw it i can't no just like
hide it and
you can do it in many ways and another
thing is to use the spot illustrations
which means that it's an illustration
without a complex background that it
works on its own
and that is really easy as well it's
not very complex backgrounds and you
need less elements and
you can express the whole idea much
faster and easier
um and of course symbolism instead of
rallies
so for a very long time i really wanted
to draw this realistic portrait
and i was beating myself up i just can't
how can i be illustrator and
not be able to do a portrait and i felt
really bad about it until one day when i
actually drew
something like that not very close not
very good but i drew it and i was like
oh that's horrible
i don't like that so i realize you don't
even need to be drawing realistically
because it's all about adding your own
style
and if you can figure out your way to
like put it out
then it doesn't matter just add your
style and it will be fine nobody cares
about realistic drawings because then
you could just take a photo right
and of course there are plenty of
artists who are really good at it so
let's leave it for them
and i think also it's important to focus
on one tool
it helped me to learn much faster
because i bought watercolor
pencils i bought paint i bought copic
markers i had bought absolutely
everything
because i just wanted to look serious
so sometimes i will just like literally
draw it in procreate print it and paint
over it so people can think that i can
paint right
then i was like okay that's just
ridiculous
it's not needed it's not necessary i can
find the clients who need the digital
drawings so
right i just decided i'll master it
first and when i'm an expert
then i can experiment with anything else
that i want
i love that thank you for sharing that i
guess i think we do get caught up in the
tools i myself and
in that way sometimes with filmmaking
whenever there's a new tool that comes
out or
everybody says i use these things these
20 things
then you all of a sudden you feel
obligated oh well if i'm considering
myself this level of professional i must
have all these tools as well
but i thank you for showing that i'm
being very honest because if you just
master one tool
and you do it well people will keep
coming to you for that same thing
over and over and over again and like
you said
once you're bored of that then maybe
you'll explore more mediums but
there's no need to jump ship until
you've mastered the one and
that is already showing in your work and
this being your first commission piece
is
pretty spectacular i gotta say just
seeing from your first illustration that
you shared with us
all the way till this one i can also see
how the idea of
the feelings and thoughts things that
might be abstract are represented here
so for instance all those shapes and
squiggles inside the hair could
represent
the the mindset of someone with autism
right thinking of all these different
things and i think that's represented in
a great way and just saying it that way
and then seeing this
i could it's all coming together now so
yeah there's some genius in your work
whether you realize it's far from genius
actually
it's all about you know like tricking
the system and finding your way in
but you know it works so it works it
ain't that stupid so like
and you know these things you like you
don't have to use all of them
like find one thing that will get you
there faster
so just simplify your life and like
don't beat yourself because you don't
know something you will figure it out
just like
find your way and finally just you know
this was my biggest weakness i didn't
know how to liter i still don't know how
to draw but
maybe we will see about that later but i
just turned it into my style
and and it works so
it brings me joy and it works for my
clients so
you can always do that as well i loved
it and that's
it and i think the only thing that this
made these three things work together
was that i showed up every single day
and i have to say i'm grateful for the
audience i have very little audience on
instagram but it was more than enough
that
when i was like crying my life out and
saying like this is just so ugly i can't
look at it but then somebody would
comment wow this is so cool and
inspired me so much and i was like how
come but anyway
it worked for somebody and if you think
you don't love it right away it's fine
because somebody else
might find it useful so just show up
every day and it will work out
eventually
so i want to touch on this thank you for
sharing all of that show up every day is
a thing that we all like to say it's
easy advice that we can give to other
people but sometimes it's hard for us to
digest ourselves right because
it takes a certain discipline or certain
rewards or incentives to be able to
to follow through with that right and
some people get the external motivation
whether that's on instagram the likes
and comments
but you know for for a lot of us as as
we're
early on in developing a skill what what
are your
what's your advice or what do you how
did you show up every day was there
anything that you did in particular
to be able to set yourself up so that
you won't give yourself an excuse and
not show up
the most rewarding was the fact that it
helped some people
because i always left some caption below
it with my journey and i was really
candid about it
and there were people who dm me like i
literally had very little few dms maybe
two or three but some people say
this post saved my life
you know and i was like no no please i
i don't have the courage even to accept
this comment like how and
like and the person said like i i was
just really down and i
couldn't like get out of bed but now i'm
ready to go
and it's like it's really rewarding when
you have
like two or three people and like my
best friend is my husband
he was my biggest fan from the beginning
from the moment when i drew on the
schnitzel and he
loved it of course he don't have a
choice but
you know just having him there and when
i was down myself like really depressed
that you know
why am i even bothering him for that he
would just literally
pick me up put me on the chair and say
you are depressed you are going to draw
now and you will feel better
so perhaps to think is like one find a
way that you can
um give to somebody maybe to your
community or it doesn't have to be even
social media
it could be a local community you could
draw or
anything you're trying to do or learn uh
with your
kids in the neighborhood like just find
your way of giving to people
because that's really rewarding and that
really keeps you moving forward
and then find your through fun one just
one
you don't need more than one fan
somebody who will believe in you no
matter what
i love that that's such a sweet sweet
story i love that it sounds like you
have a really good partner
who pushes you especially when you don't
feel like doing it but then also just
i think the very first thing that you
said about
sharing your story behind the image i
think is so important because
we live in a world where people are
very talented at making the things
making beautiful
imagery and sometimes uh
they don't tell a story behind it and i
know there's a story
people don't make things arbitrarily and
there's no
there's no no feeling or concept behind
it but sometimes people
forget about that part so i think it's
really important for our audience to
think
when they're making their own artwork to
consider
sharing the thoughts behind it being
transparent because those are the real
things that people
connect with and it actually makes the
artwork
more valuable because it gives it
meaning it's not arbitrary it's not just
pixels on the screen it's your story and
how you're feeling
that day so i think that's very
important an important insight that
um people who's considering making
content making artwork and sharing it
to to share that part about it because
it the
story underneath is the thing that makes
it even more interesting
yes that's very well and everyone has a
story to tell
everyone i will not accept if you if you
have trouble with your story just dm me
and i will tell you what's your story i
i don't accept if you say you don't have
a story to tell so
so yeah that's pretty much it and now i
would like actually to show you the
process behind the illustration we're
gonna do today
fantastic yeah so while we're setting
that up
uh jonah if you wanna i'm just gonna
look through the comments i will not
switch
yet i will just start uh showing you
what i did kind of ahead
oh okay okay fantastic just i will try
to keep it
brief so i tried to my kind of brief was
to answer the question what is happiness
and i want to go back to that conceptual
work to say that
this is something i've been working for
the past two years so again
this illustration is my story i am the
concept and this is
goes for the work i do with my clients
um and all the books i read on the
personal growth
i did ikigai method i think until my
brain health
i really couldn't figure it out so then
i had my friend radhika who
set up a call with me we did the live
session to figure it out together
and you know everything was around that
topic for me so when
chris said okay come on the show i was
like that's what i'm gonna do this is
the answer and at that time
i also finished the book which is called
the courage to be disliked
so i super recommend this book i think
it's the best personal growth book
so the answer what is happiness came
from that book
and it is basically um imagine a theater
scene
and you are performing and
how bright is the spotlight depends on
you
if you make it a little bit dim then you
will start seeing the audience in front
of you and you will start worrying what
they gonna think about me what's in the
back of me like
so you will start worrying about your
future and about your past
but if you make the spotlight really
really bright
you will not even see the audience
anymore you will not see what's in the
back
you would just like super enjoy that
moment you'll be present in the moment
you will be happy and you'll be like in
the kind of state of flow
and um not only that when you are happy
and you do 100
of performance then uh the audience in
front of you
will have the best show ever so it's not
like forget about your audience but
perform 100 so this is the answer i
found
so this was the kind of concept i love
it
and this is my sketching so here starts
the bad part of the presentation
um so in general i don't do sketches i
find it very time consuming to
bring the sketch to the final work so i
did those
i think i had five like those and i did
it in 10 minutes
because i already had a very strong
concept i knew i need a spotlight i need
a new i need a theater i need the growth
so i knew the kind of keywords and i
knew the feeling i want to show i wanted
to
show the moment enjoying having joy
but also kind of brownness and being
like really excited to be in that
i don't know spotlight so the first one
on the
top i'm not sure what's the reflection
but on the top it's really funny where
the lady is just like that
i wanted to draw a lady that's just like
literally happy and jumping
but then i was like okay this is not the
feeling i want to show to my audience
i wanted them to reflect feel calm
hopeful
and um i wanted them to feel the joy on
that lady
so the other one i did was a girl like
just bending on the pencil like really
i don't know but it was a bit too much
suffering too much drama
okay i can see that yeah i really love
this concept though and i really wanted
to do it but maybe for another purpose
and then finally i said okay it has to
be something between dancing and
maybe a dress or a floral floral coming
out of it
um but yeah i wanted to show more grace
more graceful movements
so the big sketch is the one that i kind
of settle on and as you can see it's
really ugly i mean there is
nothing cool in it so this is a good way
also to simplify your process like
before you actually start drawing like
get it out really fast just to see if
the composition makes sense and that's
all you need to know
of course if you can draw then do it
better but if you don't that's fine as
well
yeah no this is this is great actually
if we could park on that i do love that
because
uh greg has shared this a lot in some of
his videos about really doing thumbnails
or just doing very quick sketches
before you add any details it's
important to get the silhouette right
especially with illustrations so
with this one you have a character
that's posing and and i'm glad you
selected that one because
i think you chose it for the right
reason with the first one she could look
scared or surprised or excited
the you said the second one like maybe
it's like too much like
she's dying on her own sword right it's
too too dramatic
but this last one it feels like she's
joyful she's happy but she's also
finished her performance usually when an
actor on stage finishes their
performance or singing they're like
looking up and then it's like the moment
right before the applause
and so i think i think there's a story
there i'm glad you
told us the story behind it because now
this gives it so much context
and so much more meaning and so i just
wanted to
share that and everybody actually in the
comments right now are saying
thank you for sharing all of these gems
joanna like there's so many good things
in here we got a lot of
the the pro members and pro family in
here that are all
supporting and watching as well they're
all saying hello
um so so yeah i just i just wanted to
let you know that
there's there's genius here i know you
you're playing the humble
the humble card right now but there is a
lot of genius when i look at this work
oh yeah cool if you say something
i take it i take it you know i worked
hard so i would take it you know
it was just one year but you know the
pressure of this one year was really
high so
i love it um i will also reveal you know
how you can do it when it's really hard
to draw because i found the pose but
then i just couldn't throw it
and with many illustrations for my
clients are really really simple
so i can draw it right away i do this i
was really struggling so i started to
actually look for a
reference image and i found that first
lady which was like kind of
again this gentle movement and i really
like because she was really performing
but she didn't have enough energy and it
was just too calm for me
then i found the middle lady and i love
the pattern
i my work is inspired a lot by the folk
patterns and i was like i need to like
somehow combine it
make it more expressive and then i found
the third image
which i actually found on and splash
which i really really recommend if you
lose
use look for reference images
because they are free so it's a bit uh
and also the pose is there and the
people are more natural
so that's what i found those this
dancing lady
and i thought she's really beautiful
because she also looks up towards the
uh towards the light um she really don't
care for the audience but at the same
time she really performs
to her best i love it so
that's the reference image i will use
for the drawing today
okay genius no genius i will just be
popping a lot of copying will be done
all right so are we ready to get into
the demo finally
finally no i don't discount all of your
story your story's been fantastic in the
gym
everybody's so excited every uh kamiah
says
she is amazing this is so inspiring hi
i'm so happy to see you yeah yeah and
another one nandita says it's amazing
that this has only been a year i'm in
awe so a lot of fans in here
super cool i'm really happy to see
everyone i need to hear some negative
comments too
don't worry jonah's going to boot them
out they're all okay
i'm waiting i want to take it on so
um can i switch now to the yeah you can
go ahead and switch
okay let's not pray that's gonna work
out
oh see one person agrees with me wooter
says
uh at matthew and cena she really is a
genius i can vouch
okay
give us a second here people all right
yeah we're just
doing the switch over i just want to say
hi to everybody who's tuning in
got people from seoul korea from brazil
from india i think chris is joining us
greg gunn is joining us he says true
story i think about the dog thing before
bangladesh argentina romania greece
canada detroit a lot of people in here
cape town south africa
really nice to see all of you on here
yes it gives me a lot of courage yes
and from denmark fantastic
you get the global audience here they
all showed up just for you this is
i love it i'm happy i kind of don't see
them i will use that spotlight right now
for myself
we just have the zoom spotlight on you
don't worry i really have to do that
it will be easier to perform better
let me know when i'm like yeah you're
good
i'm good okay cool so i would like to
kind of
show every step um so in case if you
want to you can like kind of do it as
well
um so i'm gonna start from actually
setting up a square
canvas and i did that originally by
absolute mistake a mistake sorry by
chance
by lag it was the first setting so
that's what i used first time
and ever since this was my best setting
because it's just so much better to draw
in this uh
kind of square setup so you can use it
as well for your first drawings
and i'm going to set the background
color to black
i really like to work with the contrast
and this is all in procreate right on
your ipad okay yes
so as you can see my color palette is
still not that big
and i will start from the spotlight
so that i can get my contrast back um
i hope and actually i'm gonna use the
monoline um
brush which is actually from the future
pack the calligraphy pack
oh um kind of random but
um it's i bought it and i kind of buy a
lot of packs and then use just one brush
from each
yeah so you have to buy the whole colors
to get the one brush but that's okay
um so you also can use
a drawing guide and we're going to set
it up for symmetry
i will make it really big so i can see
it
okay that looks fine i don't need the
drawing assets
acid assist for that
okay and i'm gonna start from that
okay oh it's really hard to draw like
that i haven't
all right and i see some people have
questions here
um we'll do a little bit of q a towards
the end
i think as you're working on your uh
drawing of course i'll ask
the dumb questions because i'm the
illustrator so oh look at that
sorry my hands already um um
how to say nervous yeah no it's all
right
so i just can't get it right so okay
it's fine it's not perfect
but i'm gonna just do that so i think i
will not talk
as i draw so go ahead yeah focus on your
thing and i'll ask questions as we go
and i'll just look at the uh
the comments for now so for those of you
who are unaware she's drawing
inappropriate on her ipad procreate is a
raster based program
where it's very popular with
illustrators right now i think
unexpectedly it's taken a big share
inside of the
illustration community away from adobe
because it's just such a great
drawing tool it's very easy and it's
kind of
built without any of the the baggage
that some of the
legacy adobe programs have and i know
adobe's been doing a lot to try and
catch up
so it's really interesting to see and
the cool thing about drawing on ipad
here especially with procreate is that
there's guided tools right so you
she's drawing sometimes imperfect lines
but the software
helps do little things like make perfect
circles or snap and make perfect lines
and then there's symmetry tools so she
could just draw a line on one side
and then we'll draw the symmetry on the
other side
yeah and sometimes that's not enough
yeah even that's not enough right it's a
it's a tool it's another tool it helps
but it doesn't you know
it won't do all of the work for you but
it's definitely useful especially the
drawing assist so that you can
uh to draw with the symmetry that's
really useful and
now i'm actually going to pull out my um
cheat sheet
um so i just want to say here that
like you can use images
in very various way just as a reference
image like you look and then draw and
that's fine
and if you struggle with some parts like
don't be afraid to trace
just little parts and i'll show you how
this worked out for me here
so i'll just lower the opacity of this
gun
and i always have start drawing with the
blocks of colors
um i'm gonna zoom in so what i need from
her
is her hands because that's your
kryptonite right but
the hands are the hard ones to draw if i
could take a photo i would do that
and then um use it but in this case like
ah
this pose would be just really really
really hot
or put them behind their back again
you're right yeah
but there's an elegance to her hands and
i think that's what's really nice about
this pose
is like that just like how this right
hand is falling down
it's just it's just right
i think that's the kind sorry it's
really important for you to see
what's worth like kind of stealing
copying
what will add and what okay now i just
have some puff open
and it does not mean that you will like
copy the whole image
i also take her head
yeah i think i know a lot of us face
this as
as artists and designers as creative
people where we feel
guilty for copying or tracing but really
it doesn't matter
if you're taking something and altering
it
enough uh and you're not
using the original piece 100 you're
using parts and bits of a lot of things
just like your memories just like your
feelings just like your thoughts
you're combining all of these things and
then doing it through your lens for the
message and purpose that you want to
convey
and that's the important part right i
think um
historically uh the
one of the the biggest artists was
what was his name from the the the
dadaist
movement uh marcel duchamp all he did
was he took
a urinal he turned it on its side he
signed it and put it in a gallery and
called it art
that was one of those a groundbreaking
piece because
before then everyone was so focused on
you know all the mediums and the styles
and portraits and realism and all this
stuff where he made a big question like
what is art
and he was one who really broke a lot of
barriers and so many people
after him we're we're just combining and
bashing things together because
the key thing with art is that it has
meaning it has a message and it
it it represents something culturally of
the time of the person
and uh and it says something about the
current state of things so
i just wanted to share that because i
think a lot of us get shy
or or feel guilty about this stuff i do
it all the time
i take lots of little pieces in all of
my work all the time because i know
it it creates something meaningful
yes and if you look at the thing the
parts that i traced
this is all i needed so if you see this
it's
not really even copying the full image
so
i think you can do that without feeling
too much guilty and if you feel very
guilty that probably means you copied
too much
that's what i tell myself if it doesn't
feel right it's probably not right so
like do it until it seems um
until it's it is comfortable for you
yeah so people's asking yes she's
working on ipad
if you're curious and yeah she's
just working on procreate this is
beautiful
color palette i see you like a lot of
these
um blues and oranges is this kind of
like your lane like this is the the
colors that you really
enjoy working with or is it just for
this particular illustration
to be honest i started with the blue
itself and the
blue girl the story of the blue girl is
because of my kind of
own struggles um like i was really blue
literally i i had some postpartum
depression and
i went through all the things so i
just seen myself really really blue
and so you would say it's like a
vitrando maybe the choice
no it doesn't sound random at all it
sounds like a very strong personal
preference and you have a reason why
so genius the genius genius is not
accidental thank god that's not helping
me
i'm having such a sweaty hands i cannot
zoom on there
i cannot undo anymore i'm sorry
um so one thing is this that it was
really
literally expressing my feelings um but
also then um i was drawing a lot of
inspired a lot by the folk patterns and
they also had a lot of blues
so that's how i kind of made the
decision to keep it that way
then then cooley is tuning in she says
as a kid i learned to draw faces by
tracing over my mom's fashion magazines
that's pretty cool yeah uh ali pineda's
on here too
he says i'm not an illustrator but you
make it look so easy joanna you're
awesome
okay guys i i rephrase it for like
rehearse it for a long time
so i just really don't
i think i really wanted for this to
don't look easy
to wait sorry i wanted it to look simple
but
not easy um
i want you to see the struggle because
it's
i don't know it's true it's like um not
perfect
i don't know how to explain but i will
add the project files as well
okay so that you can download and you
can see in photoshop the layers or
uh on procreate as well oh that's very
generous of you thank you for doing that
and i would be really happy because i
added that also a sketch so i would be
really happy to see if someone could
take the sketch
and um even like trace it over like
steal from me i'm really happy to
do that to give you that and um
draw it in your style i love it that's a
good challenge so she's gonna
give you all the assets essentially her
layered file and her sketch
and her challenge to all of you is to
make your version of that use your style
feel free to use hers as a base and then
just build off of that
i think copying early on especially from
people who are doing something well
is one of the easiest ways to learn and
get better i know for me as
a child when i was first starting to get
my feet wet into
art i had a bunch of comic books and i
would copy the characters all the time
trying to copy line for a line
spider-man or wolverine like they were
never perfect
but doing that helped me understand
shape and form a little bit better it
helped me understand anatomy
and kind of set me on my way to to
pursue a creative career
so even though i haven't retained a lot
of those skills because i don't practice
my drawing so much anymore
that definitely helped early on and even
as a designer
the same thing you know i'd study all
these different uh design trends that i
really liked when i was coming up in
2003 and 2004 when i was first starting
graphic design
i was really into album art for
uh all of these punk bands and and at
the time there's
this grunge thing because of david
carson and all these other
inspirational designers and artists
really influenced
that look and so you know i ended up
copying a lot of that stuff and
it becoming a part of my work even until
this day so
whenever you're learning something new
don't be afraid to copy it as a as a
form of learning
just pay homage and respect to those who
came before you and don't try to claim
the work as your own
yes and i think i learned that from
chris actually it was strange because
there is no
proper channel for you know there is
there is a lot of illustrator
um like tutorials for illustration
but they are so good i just don't know
how they got there sometimes
i'm like you know it's hard for me to
trace it back and i actually held chris
saying like if you want to learn
something
just take a logo and draw it
uh try to trace it and redraw it so i
think that's where i got the idea from
yeah at art center when we were first
taking typography classes
i hated some of it because the the
exercises were so much
that it's like okay you want to learn
typography here's the typeface now draw
every single letter
and drop ten times every single serif
every single line every single curve
and draw it with pencil and then trace
over it and do it again and again again
and then again and as much as you know i
didn't
fully enjoy that because it wasn't the
most creative thing in the world
it helped me understand letter forms it
helped me understand spacing and
what makes a particular letter like the
capital r
looks so unique and it made me
appreciate the details and then
after obviously i have a better
relationship with
how how to use typography letter by
letter word for word
and i think actually everyone does it
in to some degree so i will never forget
that i was so ashamed of it that
you know sometimes i have to trace
something or i need more
reference images and then i talk to one
illustrator and i say how did you do
that and she's like i traced it
ah what no way like why
why why nobody told me that that's like
to think that you can like do this you
know
i was i was upset
why why now why nobody told me earlier
well now you know and now we're trying
to share this with our audience so
if anyone has ever had that question now
you know feel free to trace over stuff
build it just you know in a healthy way
let's say
yeah so i also want to add that how i
draw is that i always draw the shape
first
even if it's like not good or perfect
and then i try to figure it out
so if something is like not a good shape
then i would
so i don't have this perfect sketch and
thanks to that actually that's
how some crazy ideas are born because if
i had a sketch which is like perfect and
already kind
of set up i wouldn't kind of come up
with some ideas
if that makes sense yeah no i know
exactly what you mean it's kind of like
you drew a skeleton first and now you're
drawing the
the form on top of it the muscles and
all the details
and what's cool about that it's kind of
like a coloring book that you're
uh inclined to go outside of the lines
right so you had a nice little shape of
a silhouette basic silhouette but i love
how you're breaking
that silhouette with this nice flowy
dress and that flowy puffy hair
i definitely get that feeling that
there's something lush about that and
there's something that's very rich about
that so
you know as you describe the story and
as you describe your process like these
are things that i
can observe and i can see
you know why you're choosing to do what
you do and like the benefit of those
things like why you have this particular
process
i'll just go into the comments nikki was
saying i grew up in an artistic family
they do
things that are very high realism oil
paints on wood or on canvas
almost like rembrandt that made me so
insecure of my own illustrations and
copying parts of
photos and i didn't think that industry
professionals
actually trace stuff it feels so wrong
to me but the thing is like
everyone i've met has lifted copied
borrowed traced it
or something for their work
and i don't know how you could
it not operate in life without
having all of these various inputs to
influence your work
it's a way again i think for art it's
just a way for you to communicate your
message and as a designer
for you to communicate the the message
of your clients
so by any means as long as you're not
stealing and i think this is where
people get caught up right
they feel like it's stealing but it's
only stealing if you're
taking 100 of the thing if you're taking
99 or 98
but if you're adding if you're taking
maybe 10 of one thing 10
of another thing and then putting 100 of
yourself
in it that's not stealing anymore
and i think you will feel it where is
like kind of the line
you will know when it doesn't feel right
i love that you lean into your intuition
so much into your process
because some of us at the future maybe
chris
it's quite robotic with stuff and he
doesn't always talk about feelings but i
know he has a lot of good intuition too
but he rarely talks about that when he's
designing like his his whole goal is to
try and show you
things objectively it's like well you do
this because of this and then
it's a cause and effect right but it's
nice to
hear it from somebody like you who just
leads into intuition
a lot it's like oh it's wrong when it
feels wrong
yeah and you know it's it's refreshing
to hear that
but also you know like i know why chris
does the things that he does is because
he's just trying to show you that
um there is a reason why you do things
and
you if you follow a process you can get
better so your process is different and
it's actually nice to see all of your
little mistakes in here as you're
drawing right
the program is no i love it i think
everybody appreciates that
you know like being able to see that you
have to draw it three times five times
before it actually works right because
you're not just like a robot or you can
just do it in one stroke and it's done
it's like oh no
let's work on that curve again again
again
and part of that intuition is developed
from
tracing over other things studying other
people's work and saying
what does an elegant curve look like
what are elegant
you know color combinations what really
works together
and you you don't know those things
until you study and practice
okay chris chris is in the comments he
says i have no feelings
beep boop it's a lie
it's just uh we just don't know we just
don't see them
he doesn't wear his feelings on his
sleeve
okay this is not perfect shoes but the
reason actually i put her in the shoes
because i couldn't stand the feet
and it just i couldn't make it look so i
don't draw really realistically i
couldn't find a symbol for a fit
i don't want it to be too cartoony
either
so on the end i was like okay she's
going to wear shoes that's it
and because they are kind of these
folklore shoes that kind of fit so
i love it if it doesn't work in your
favor just like kill it
you just cover it up yeah exactly the
hands or the feet
totally okay
i think we got the shape more or less
uh ahmed and the comment says oh my god
these laces in the shoe are adorable
oh my god that's cool i love those
comments you know i love it because
i was i'm so worried sometimes this
looks so bad it's so unperfect you know
but
yeah it works for somebody
okay now the best part the magic
um with shading
that's where you actually start seeing
it looking good
so until this part i usually do it
really really fast because i'm impatient
i don't want to spend more time on
making shapes because that's boring but
um when i can finally start adding the
making the feeling alive
[Music]
oh there we go it feels so good i don't
know
see it is very satisfying so you're
making layers right now
and you're applying it only to the layer
below it right that's what you're doing
on the on the layer panel there
exactly and that's super easy also
because we know the light is coming from
the top
so in a complex scene i would really
struggle because you know you have the
natural light the light from
the lamps or something but in spot
illustrations usually you have no more
than one
source of light and also you are in
charge so
if you struggle with shading and lights
just don't put light in just make it one
just make it flat i love how you get rid
of problems
yeah i love it that's a that's a good
way to eat it for yourself
that's right get rid of the problem
you don't have to solve it you just get
skirt around the problem that's one way
to
to deal with it rick told me about a
girl that
he was saying that she broke her arm and
she had to she struggled with opening
jars
and then uh rick is like oh so what'd
you do
she's like i stopped buying jars
it's that simple it's that simple
oh i love that we sometimes we forget
about that it's like
do i really have to deal with this
problem this way is there only one
binary solution because
we're creative creative people can think
around the problem
and it also comes down how much do you
really want it
do you really want to eat that jar that
food
right yes okay you're gonna find a way
to open it even with your tooth
that's right
van is saying yes the shading and the
highlights make it come alive
lovely so this is very simple trick
actually so if anyone wants to do it on
anything else all you have to do is add
layer on the top of the object that is
below
if that makes sense set it to multiply
and make a clipping mask and that means
again your shapes doesn't even have to
be perfect
right so it's staying within the bounds
of the uh
the pixels that are uh underneath it
there oh
i see yeah that's why
she had all the layers like going up
you're making one layer at a time
because you knew ahead of time that you
wanted to add these kind of shadows
yes i think traditional illustrator
might be able to actually
draw it like you know as one piece with
the shading and that's super cool and
i'm super super jealous for that
but i could never figure it out
and probably i will at some point
but until i mastered this one i would
just let it go so that i can enjoy a
little bit the illustration as well
so we don't need this line at all
anymore
yes i think we are just missing the hair
let's light up the hair as well
aditi in the comments to shang i've
really this is looking really amazing i
love her style this is so beautiful
thank you yeah this is cool i love
seeing
you work this way and it's it's nice to
see you
have all these layers and and what
you're doing with them to really give it
depth because you know i already thought
that the illustration
looked good prior to the shading but
this definitely adds so much
more to that and i i'm sure this is one
of those things that you developed when
we were looking at your illustrations
from the beginning where it was very
flat
and just shapes first and then you could
see the jump where you learned how to
do shading and lighting and you added
that as a as an element in your drawing
oh no some imperfections
so this you can kind of fix on the end
and then again in that way you don't
really need to know how to draw the full
you know life drawing posture you just
kind of do it shape by shape
and find your way through i think
something is wrong with her face
so i have a i have a question for you
and this came up earlier in the chat
i know that this is just a fictitious
brief for yourself what is happiness and
you walked us through that process and
you have
the references when you're working with
a client is that
process the same and if so how do you
share the various steps of the process
with your client like do you show them
the reference and talk them through that
or
what does that look like relative to to
what you're showing us today
it is very much similar i do for them
the ugly sketches as well
i try to warn them before like this is
not pretty but
it's it's the fastest way and i think
actually my clients
like it that we can do this pretty much
fast i think the process is the same
okay the only difference is i really try
to ask them
who is their audience so we i enter a
little bit into this branding strategy
mode which i learned from the other
field
because i really want to understand the
feelings that they would like to show
right but that's i think the only
difference
so after you understand their brief and
their audience and what they're trying
to say then you go into
sketch mode and research mode so you
pull in
references as a mood board you have a
couple of thumbnail sketches
and you talk them through that just like
you talked us through right like here's
the story here's what i see here's what
i heard
and here's how translated that this is
what it could be
but you haven't committed to all the
details yet so you're not spending all
the time
detailing an illustration like this
because we know that it could take you a
very long time
but you're you're holding their hand in
allowing the client to
uh be a part of the process and build it
with you right
yes i think it's essential because i
think i also learn it from chris it's
funny because we don't have our show
like this which is a bit more candid
um so i learned also this like with the
stylescapes and everything i do
so if i showed the client just the final
illustration
99 sure that they kind of wouldn't
accept it yeah but if i can involve them
on the process and make them also feel
like they drew it
they really like it
yeah it makes them feel creative and and
they're more bought into the idea
because they make the decisions with you
if you just show up with the solution
you know because they have no hand in it
they're
less likely to buy it unless you for
some reason knock it out of the park and
you're
you're a super genius superstar and i
think it's
also important that i do commercial work
sorry for flipping this
but not um so illustrators do this a lot
i didn't skip that step because it's
just
you feel more the gravity if you flip
the clip it so
otherwise i would not be able to draw
the leaves that that good
or that fast at least i tried it but
sorry this is not going to be
professional
no this is um this is very professional
i i mean
anyone who's drawn anything before right
like you rotate your paper because
certain like movements especially with
curves you need a certain range of
motion with your hand
and if if you're kind of confined and
you can't draw the perfect curve
of course you just rotate your paper and
then you get that full range of motion
back in your
your hand so or in your arm so this is
fantastic
these details i thought you were already
done with the shading the fact that
you're adding another
layer of lines i i love it uh i just
keep thinking it's like
what other details can she add to make
this look even better and it just keeps
getting better and better
this is my biggest problem so i don't
like making the shape but i
love working on the details and i just
can't stop
uh it's um so one of the reasons why i
actually started drawing is because
i was really like on the rock bottom
like i couldn't be literally worse
and i was like okay now i have nothing
left so let's just do the thing i always
wanted to do because like
now nothing else to lose right so i
started to draw because i found it super
therapeutic
and i could hyper focus for hours on
those details
and i think it's therapeutic for many
people like if you feel bad just start
you know some people just feel the
squares in the notebooks
i'm not sure if you if you do that as
well i i've done that i've done that in
many way notebooks
so that's very therapeutic so i actually
study a lot about art therapy
because it worked on me so well so i
would love one day to teach
some kids you know who really need it
and if you feel bad just like you know
sit and focus on the drawing because
that puts you in the state of flow
which is another state of happiness
i'm very fixated on this topic sorry no
no i love it please keep keep going i
mean
that's what your husband did for you
right whenever you're not in a good
state he's like he picks you up and put
you in your chairs like okay go draw
because
this is therapy and and i could see it
it's mesmerizing to watch you draw this
and i've been in similar states too
where i'm just like
why do i keep reshading this thing over
and over why do i keep redrawing this or
why do i keep
adjusting this detail it's like when you
watch designers
play with typography and they keep
adjusting the kerning two pixels left
one pixel right oh three pixels left uh
let's move it out let's make it a little
bit bigger it's the same thing there's a
there's there is therapy in in refining
the details or
exaggerating the details there wow this
is
this is amazing that is fine i hope
that's that is amazing it is not the end
oh my gosh oh
wait wait wait
lost 10 kilograms here but
i think i'm gonna get it done oh this is
no i was really prepared but one thing i
didn't
prepare for is that my hands will get
sweaty
i cannot do that
you got to get some talcum powder some
baby powder in there
i have so much things to learn about
making tutorials
there's a uh i don't know if you know
anything about rock climbing but
rock climbers they want to keep their
hands dry all the time so they
they chalk up before right you could do
that the next time you're on the street
just shut up your hands and it will stay
dry
that's a good idea i'm not sure if i
would survive mentally another
live stream like this but
you're doing fantastic yeah people are
saying yes
uh van is saying yes creating is
therapeutic and watching people create
is calming all of this
i almost feel like i'm watching a time
lapse you you do i know you've prepared
to work on this but
you know a lot of this seems pretty
effortless
it's beautiful it is definitely
part of some practice because then again
i chose to specialize
in those colors um in the patterns that
i draw i use them really really often
so it's not only cheating everything but
i do
like draw these things all over again
and actually i picked quite hard drawing
i admit
um but it's just it was the right thing
to do i don't know how to explain it but
you know i went through personal growth
journey and i got my clients but i was
like
i still need something you know like can
i really do it like
if somebody would be watching me and
then
this happened and i was like yes this is
this is it that's it
no more stress for me i'm done i did
everything
wow this is cool i think she's ready
wow so you duplicated it and then kept
it
use the the spotlight on the bottom the
base as the
the mask for it i just flipped her
around and that was pretty easy i think
i just don't like
her hurt so much
just one little fix
no don't apologize this is satisfying to
watch
like what's happening here yeah so the
thing is if you first make something bad
it does not
matter like don't get discouraged at
that stage like just keep moving and
like keep fixing it and
it's gonna work just like trust the
process
or just cover it up
this is great um so as you're finishing
up i
i know there was a question early and i
know we're going to transition into a
little bit of q a
this is beautiful and obviously you've
spent a year getting to this
point how did you get your first paid
client
because i know you shared with us which
illustration that was but
how did that happen
um so i think one part of it is the
showing up
every day and making it public
um the other thing is like talking about
it to your friends
people you know so i just talked about
it like all over again
and this was actually a client
from the people i know
so i just kept talking and like you
could really get bored of me talking
about me drawing and
then this the lady who's actually in
charge of the company she saw my
illustration on
instagram and she was really a big fan
from the beginning
wow and then when they needed something
they just reached out and
i was kind of ready for it so it was
nothing
not very not a lot of sales tax tactics
there besides
showing up and at that point how big was
your audience do you think
on instagram yeah yeah oh maybe 300 400
people
it's i think this is irrelevant it's
more about relationship building
so i specialize in that topic
and that skill i talk about it to
everyone
everywhere so when they have something
to do with that thing
they call me they don't call the girl
who's so much better in drawing
not that she's worse or i am better
know that reason is just i am like kind
of there
if that makes sense so just put yourself
out there i would say
no and i i think i i asked that just to
demonstrate to our audience that
you don't have to have 10 000 followers
you don't have to have a hundred
thousand followers in order to get
clients the fact that you are
doing the work every day you're sharing
stories
and you're trying to specialize in
something like combining your love for
mental health with the illustrations
that you're drawing and the stories that
you can tell behind it
what happens is you get known
for that thing and even if it's within a
tight circle
that tight circle has many degrees to it
of people that can be folded in
that are looking for the thing that
you're doing so i
i i just wanted to share all of that and
it's nice to that you have the
transparency and
also the ability to say look i landed a
client with only 300 followers but it
was through instagram
and i was just doing my thing every
single day
and i think i have to add to it like if
you do something let's say for instagram
just like put it everywhere
be that annoying person stock absolutely
every social media channel
because i the next client and actually
the
client who paid triple the amount wow
came from twitter
i didn't know i'm there somebody
reshared a tweet on twitter my
uh image i don't know how
but that's how he found me and it was
very well paid work
i really loved it it was on topic it
just everything fell
into the pieces together and i want to
actually share
something with that and i i think one
beautiful thing about your work i mean
obviously it looks good
but you gave a reason for somebody to
share it
people don't necessarily share artwork
because they think it's beautiful
sometimes they'll share something
digitally on their social media platform
because it's worth sharing meaning
there's a story attached to this and i'm
sure if we dig back we might be able to
find like
maybe somebody really resonated with the
story that was being told there
in the post it's like i'm feeling this
today this is my mood today right people
love
um sharing artists work to help
represent how they feel because they
don't
they don't have a way to articulate that
themselves so by you arming them with
an image a story it makes it very
shareable and
helps you grow your network or your
influence within
even a small network so these are all
things that
we can learn from and i think are
important for people to understand as
they
put content out there as they make their
artwork as they
uh try to land clients
and i think it's also type of the
clients that it's much better
because then we can talk about thinking
behind it i can really use my
strategy knowledge so i say like what do
you want your clients to feel i because
i really
hate the traditional drawing just for
the purpose of drawing it really bugs me
so it and if they paid you know 1000
2000 euros for one illustration
i want them to use it well so when you
add the captions and kind of thinking
behind it that sets you up
expose you to better type of clients who
also appreciate your thinking behind it
so i think this is
also the future lessons but i kind of
apply it to the illustration world as
well
yeah these are life lessons so i want to
queue up our audience if you have any
particular questions
start asking them now but i do have a
question
because your background is in branding
and design
and you made a transition here what
was the thing that made you want to
change and then what did you have to
overcome in that period
i first actually i'm in this soft
transition so at the moment i do
branding with illustration
okay this helps me to make the
illustration a bit more useful
because i created the whole system for
the brand
[Music]
so i wouldn't say i fully transitioned
i'm still like trying to figure to find
my place maybe if that makes sense
because i'm really doing it differently
um
but what made you made me want to shift
is because i could see that
i'm not fully enjoying for example
designing logos
so i was just not good at it and i was
not good at it because i didn't know how
to draw
and then i got a job as an art director
and then you also have to sketch right
you also have to do
and actually i think you helped me get
that job so thank you on the side note
but um either way i thought like okay
this is
one skill that i'm missing that's
holding me back from doing what i love
no matter what i do whether i will be
professional illustrator or stay in
branding
and i think again that came from
brian tracy's book the power of
self-confidence where he says like
whatever you want to do there are just
seven essential skills that you need in
order
to achieve it and i was like okay okay
what's that what's that and
unfortunately always it was just coming
back to me it's
you need to learn to draw
so i just knew no matter how hard i try
to avoid this
skill i need to learn how to draw in
order to do what i love to do
so i think that's what moved me forward
and i just wish i did it earlier maybe
because then i could be really a genius
by now but
yeah it was meant to be like that so
that's why i would say to everyone like
if something is stopping you from doing
what you love like just find one skill
that is missing and kill it first
because that's gonna bring you closer to
what you want to do
did it answer the question no that's
fantastic so
you didn't make a full transition you
are leveraging all the things that
you've done before and i think
when most people think of a career
switch they think they have to dump
everything
from their past and not leveraged all of
the stuff that have come
up to this point and it's it's funny
that you've been avoiding the
need to draw for so long and then that
was actually the answer the thing that
needed to be unlocked for you to see a
different future for yourself
to see other opportunities so with that
there's there's some questions here
um some basic ones like uh how often do
you post on instagram
um i i do try to do it every day but
what i did is i post i no sorry
my rule is i need to give something to
my audience every day
now how i do this it depends on the time
available
and kind of my current mood and state
and everything
so if i don't have the time but i'm
working on something i would take the
sketch and post it to patreon because
then i post like the kind of work in
progress
um if i really don't have time maybe i
would just add something to this so i
have a different mindset i'm not gonna
set a rules that i cannot follow because
it's the same like with you know
exercise i will not do this anyway it's
just too difficult
so i my rule is like i have to give
something to my audience every day
i love it that's fantastic okay
uh another question if you're
comfortable with answering this uh how
do you price your work
with illustration actually that's a
really really good question i think
we're missing it a bit in the
illustration world which is
you have to the price based
on uh many factors which is how much
detail it will involve
and the most important is licensing
every illustrator shouldn't know that
and i didn't know it in the beginning so
i would
say charge 500 euros for illustration
like this
and they would get all the exclusive
rights and that's it and then somebody
told me
never ever do that if they want it
on exclusive rights this illustration
you could sell at thousand euros let's
say
right so you almost doubled
and perhaps it depends also on where you
are
in your skill set and what value you add
to the illustration because i also i put
a lot of work on the conceptual part
like i don't take
many illustrations when they tell me
draw a table right
i just don't know how to do this it's
right i don't know how to draw you know
so
it's really hard for me but if they give
me the freedom to experiment with the
concepts then i can kind of find the way
always so
i think i make my pricing a bit higher
also because of the conceptual work but
i think
the key is the licensing right so
just so it's clear to our audience and
licensing there's many ways to do it
one is you own the ip and they could
license it for
a certain level like we're using it in
this country in this context for this
long
or we're using it in print only for this
long
so you have limited terms and that's
where you can keep the prices a little
bit
lower if they want to use it in
perpetuity forever and ever
in all the universe everywhere then
that's where you get to charge the most
amount of money because
either they have full ownership of the
artwork after you create it
or they have license to use it however
they want
and with that you should definitely be
charging
more for the work right so those are
just different layers things to consider
um why something can be valuable and
that's your leverage
ultimately um as as an artist as an
illustrator as a designer for some of
these things
and i think try to add value to your
work because all of you have this
strategic mindset so like
i tell my clients we will draw just one
okay it's not a cheap
maybe even 2 000 euros but you can take
this illustration now and put it in your
social media
assets you can use it on your website
you can use it on t-shirts
you have so much assets from just one
illustration that
it will save you like another 2 000
euros on creating those assets
so we would use it as a templates for
social media i would
always work on layers so they can cut it
up so
try to find the ways to add value to the
work itself
it can up your pricing as well i think i
love that so if you make it modular if
you make it a system like designers do
right like a brand identity system then
they can
make more out of it so it's not just one
flat piece that oh here's one instagram
post
but it's like well now we can replicate
it across all of our
marketing collateral so here's a here's
another question
um from jsk it says how do i develop my
own illustration style or
find it do you have any advice or
thoughts on that
um there is one simple exercise you can
use my sketch for it or make a sketch or
just
trace something and then find your five
favorite artists
any of them whatever you find visually
best and conceptual part
is good and then just draw the same
sketch in five different styles
and it's not possible i really don't
believe it would be possible for you to
fully copy the style of somebody
so you will start saying okay i like
these noses i like this
like i love the chicks and i think i
took it from a children's book
um i love the hair but you know every
part of my illustration
style comes from a different aspect
so perhaps one sketch but in a different
styles and this should help you out a
bit
yeah and then i don't know like when so
when you're
exploring other styles
is it when you're drawing it when you
say you like something is it just
because
it's fun to draw that detail or just
like oh you know when i combine this
with this it looks interesting together
is there any more on the thought process
that you can uh maybe help us understand
on that
i think it's both so first you do need
to enjoy what you draw so i really love
uh floral patterns and i just use it
always so i study a lot of those i have
a lot of plants at home i study them i
take photos
of it so also choosing like some things
you like to draw it will help you out
again specializing in something like i
love drawing women
so i take all the projects of women and
that makes it easier for me to find the
style
um yeah i think that's it does it make
sense
yeah no fantastic let's see a few more
questions here and then we could wrap
up uh let's see is there a market for
more simple designs in comparison to
more
complicated realistic ones i've always
refrained from posting my work for fear
it might
not be as refined or complex
complex doesn't mean good
i love that and i actually love
realistic work i'm a big fan of many
illustrators
but there are just very few who make it
unique
and um i had a life drawing class
in my university it was my nemesis from
the beginning
and i went to the teacher like i don't
know how to draw this life drawing and i
just don't get it i
and i was a straight a student so i was
like i don't want to mess it up
and the teacher told me you don't need
to be realistic
and on the end i ended up having an a
from the class
and students who draw real life drawings
had a c
or b just because they couldn't find
their styles so
actually i think that's the last thing
you should worry about
complex is doesn't mean good love that
okay last question here and i think we
could wrap up
is do you have any advice for someone
who
wants to draw and illustrate visual
metaphors
like how do you how do you come up with
your conceptual illustration
and maybe that's too big of a and a
question to answer and
but if you have any thoughts on that i
think it would be worth unpacking those
just so people might be able to connect
the dots for themselves
i think i think it's just growth draw it
from your experience
does it make sense so like from your
everyday
challenges if we talking about like
social media posts
i don't know if it makes sense so the
conceptual part comes from you
that's just like put yourself your
personality your experiences
anything you any challenges you overcame
yeah i i i to help you out on that one
because
i haven't i've never i don't know if
i've answered this question either
but what you're saying is what does it
mean to you
if you have a brief if you have a
challenge if there's something you want
to communicate you
do the word cloud right you you write a
bunch of thoughts so you sketch a bunch
of things
what does this mean to you what can that
look like
and you just exhaust the exploration and
then you look at that
and you see well which ones are the most
unique which are the things that i can
combine together but still work together
right
chris uses this analogy actually now i
know chris uses analogies like
conceptual thinking or good design is
like a rubber band
if you don't stretch it enough it's
boring it's obvious and it's okay
if you stretch it too much meaning
you're trying to be too abstract about
this thing the rubber band's gonna break
and make sense to nobody
but if you pull it just enough it's
gonna have this great
tension between the two points and still
make sense and create that nice
aha moment for somebody so i think it's
hopefully these things are helpful for
people to understand
you're just trying to exhaust things
that people are
you are familiar with and other people
might be familiar with in terms of
symbols and imagery and type
connecting the dots in interesting ways
and trying to stretch that as much as
possible
without breaking the concept and i'll
add just one last thing i promise
and i love the technique of idea cooler
which means you have an idea cooler
where you throw all your ideas
and let them be there cool down you
don't act on them ever
but you i keep them on my board and then
i would add to them
so i had this experience it fits to that
concept i will add i will add and i let
them be there
and i wait for the day where the right
brief comes or where
the moment of uh inspiration for the
social media post comes
and then i just pick for the ideas that
are already there i just kind of had to
connect the dots
i love that so maybe uh if you're
comfortable with sharing it later on uh
instagram if you could share a story or
post of your idea cooler if you're okay
with sharing that
i personally would love to see that
because i think it will help us connect
the dots like what does that look like
i never thought of it that way i do have
some form of that but mine
is everywhere but i should contain it in
one place and
so i'm definitely going to take that tip
and figure out how that looks like
for me so with that i think this is a
good place to wrap
up the show i want to say thank you so
much for sharing your beautiful work
with us your process
and your story i think there's a lot of
gems in here
that we can abstract if people want to
find more out about you
where can they go um
instagram perhaps because it contains
all the stories so it's vero joanna with
double r and and double n
we will have it there for you also yes
thank you again for sharing with us
uh thank you all of you who have joined
us live and if you have
follow-up questions uh don't forget to
drop it in the the comments when the
video goes uh
live and don't forget to follow joanna
and
uh listen to her story see what
resonates with you there because i'm
sure you'll find
a lot in her content so
thank you all we will uh wrap up there
and we'll see you
in the future bye-bye